dli Qual è la capitale della Francia
crossa
stupido La maestra è tonta ah Che cos'è
quello donalo il mio
iPhone
Ah sono
arrabbiatissima sono la maestra trista
ossa e oggi
verifica Chi ha studiato vincerà il
libro di Anita e chi non ha
studiato le distruggerò il
cellulare No ma io ho appena comprato il
mio nuovo iPhone 15 Pro ma tanto son
sicuro di poter copiare e non riuscirà a
distruggermi Meno male ho studiato ma
spero di aver studiato abbastanza Spero
che non distrugga il mio di cellulare Il
mio ha già lo schermo rotto però ho
paura che me lo distrugga meglio
metterlo via io col mio telefono vecchio
altro anche questi nuovi cellulari eh Il
mio telefono è proprio migliore
indistruttibile e non si scarica la
batteria Ora faremo l'interrogazione di
geografia Ditemi subito Qual è la
capitale
d'Italia Roma Sì sì Roma bravi ma questa
qui era troppo facile Qual è la capitale
della Francia Vediamo se lo sai la
capale la
Francia
crossa
[Musica]
perch No è
Parigi è quella della Germania Questa la
so al
100%
[Musica]
[Applauso]
dier
stupido fatto malissimo cos fa ero
sicuro che fosse mio ma Ma cosa Fusia la
capitale di dove io sono nato è Berlino
perché i mio i son tedesco ia ia è
quella della Spagna qual è È quella
della
[Musica]
Spagna St Non lo
so Ma cosa stai dicendo e
[Musica]
Madrid Ah Ah che cappello Ahia Ufa sono
stanca eh di te Billy Anita Dimmi qual è
la capitale dell'Ungheria Sì la so la so
è Budapest Brava Anita Almeno tu studi
sempre mio cellulare è Salvo per ora Ora
tocca a Vitale Vitale Qual è la capitale
della Grecia Io lo so io lo so e se non
lo sai ti spetter le
ossa e e poi con questa gomma ti
cancellerò la faccia mi V spezza le
Rossa mi cancella la
faccia capitale della
Grecia
Atene Atene e
adene bravo Vitale te la sei
scampata schiappe Dimmi qual è la
capitale della
Svizzera Questa è difficilissima eh Tu
pensi che io dica Zurigo perché tutti
credono che sia Zurigo la capitale della
Svizzera e Berna Berna bellissima città
Io sono andato molte volte a Berna ho
fatto dei corsi meravigliosi ho scoperto
il non mi ricordo bene neanche il nome
però era la cellula fotochimica la
cellula fotochimica è andata oltre il
tubo di
trulla
Caria Sì però basta schiappe Non è
giusto però basta raccontarci la storia
della tua vita Ciao sono l'emoji di
Anita A proposito di lupi mannari e
vampiri nel mio nuovo libro La città
stregata c'è una trasformazione in lupo
mannaro è un mistero da risolvere se non
ce l'hai ancora Prendilo subito perché
per i primi a prenderlo ci sarà in
regalo un poster autografato e ricordati
di cliccare mi piace sotto a questo
video prov a cliccare mi piace entro 3
secondi 3 2 1 tempo scaduto Oh basta Ma
perché sempre io devo subire la Furia
della maestra Ho un'idea questa volta
userò il cellulare così potrò trovare
tutte le risposte su
internet e Adesso torniamo alla mia
vittima
preferita Billy Dimmi qual è la capitale
del Regno Unito la capitale del Regno
Unito
Londra giusto Billy mi ha sorpreso e
adesso dimmi qual è la capitale
dell'Irlanda la capitale
dell'Irlanda Dublino Eh ma non è giusto
stai
barando Fatti i fatti tuoi
secchiona Bravo Billy maestro AB barat
Billy l'ho visto io no Sì sì l'abbiamo
visto noi sta guardando il cellulare di
nascosto
cosa No no maestro no no no no no no il
mio iPhone No il mio iPhone maest No non
gli
faccio così Imp Questo è il primo
avvertimento Se ti comporti di nuovo
male te lo spaccherò questo cellulare E
soprattutto non vincerai il libro di
Anita Ah no Il mio telefono devo trovare
un modo per riprendermelo e adesso
verifica di matematica copiate quello
che scrivo la
lavagna adesso che la maestra È
distratta Ho un'idea per riprendermi il
cellulare gli farò un bello
[Musica]
scherzetto La maestra è tonta che
cos'era questo rumore La maestra è tonta
Chi è che usa dire che io sono tonta
provieni da lì vado a vedere adesso che
è uscito dalla classe posso andare a
riprendermi il
cellulare La maestra è tonta ah Che
cos'è quello la maestra tra è T
Che cos'è questo che cos'è questo ma
questo qui sembra Billy Infatti si
assomiglia anche con gli occhiai
capelli Infatti si assomiglia anche con
gli occhiai capelli
basta
basta me la puoi smettere di ricopiarmi
pui smettere di ricopiare
Billy questo l'hai messo tu lì e ora
questa qui è la tua
punizione maestra Hai fatto
malire Scusa che cos'è quello è il
cellulare che ti avevo
sequestrato no no no no no non è non
come sembra No Entra No io ti avevo
avvisato adesso questo
cellulare lo
[Musica]
distruggo ha rotto il telefono il
telefono
rotto il mio telefono
no il mio telefono No che brutta fine
che hai fatto No avevo solo un giorno di
vita Billy Ben ti sta così Imp
pari non avevo mai visto un telefono
esplodere in questo modo è stato un po'
divertente devo dire Billy se l'è un po'
cercata l'aveva anche detto la maestra
di non usare i cellulari Altrimenti li
avreb distrutti Ed ora è il momento del
premio
Sì ce l'abbiamo tutti e tre
veramo te lo posso leggere il mio nuovo
libro La città stregata che ora è
disponibile online in libreria se ancora
non ce l'avete andate subito a prendere
Lino Ma te piace
studiare Mi sembra che m mi sembra che
mi ha detto di sì mi ha detto che gli
piace studiare e
ciao ciao